but we begin with horrifying new details
about the attack on Paul Pelosi and the
alleged plot against house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi so according to authorities a man
accused of breaking into her home and
attacking her husband wanted to
interrogate Nancy Pelosi believing she
was telling lies he allegedly told
authorities if he didn't like the
answers or he thought she was lying he
was prepared to in his words break her
kneecaps
David depap now faces multiple charges
including attempted murder he'll be
arraigned later today Jonathan bigliotti
is outside the speaker's house in San
Francisco Jonathan good morning to you
as bad as his story is it could have
been so much worse these details are
just stunning
they are and good morning to Gail
Federal officials really describing a
very disturbing plan saying the suspect
arrived here at this home early Friday
morning with a bag of items to take
Nancy Pelosi hostage they say he
intended to tie her up and assault her
using a hammer
this was politically motivated San
Francisco D.A Brook Jenkins was clear
about what investigators say were the
alleged attackers intentions early
Friday morning this house and the
speaker herself were specifically
targets of the defendant Jenkins said
there was no security at the home when
David depap broke in armed with two
hammers zip ties tape and a rope the
defendant made his way upstairs locating
Mr Pelosi in his bed sleeping he woke
him up confronting him about the
whereabouts of speaker Pelosi Paul
Pelosi told a Pap his wife would not be
home for several days according to the
newly released criminal complaint at one
point the speaker's husband was able to
go to the bathroom which is where he
called 9-1-1 two police officers arrived
at the front door two minutes after that
9-1-1 call when that door was opened the
defendant was holding his hammer which
Mr Pelosi appeared to be attempting to
control by holding a portion of that
hammer the defendant then pulled the
hammer away from Mr Pelosi and violently
struck him in the top of his head at
that point Jenkins said police
immediately apprehended the suspect
according to the complaint to Pap then
told police his plan was to hold Nancy
hostage and talk to her if she told the
truth he would let her go and if she
lied he was going to break her kneecaps
saying she would then have to be wheeled
into Congress showing other members
there were consequences to actions the
pap also explained generally that he
wanted to use Nancy Pelosi to lure
another unnamed individual with the
midterm elections a week away and
threats against officials escalating the
D.A called on everyone to tone down the
rhetoric we should be able to all engage
in Passionate political discourse but
still remain respectful of one another
and Nancy Pelosi said in a statement her
husband is making steady progress
recovering from a fractured skull
meanwhile officials say they intend to
hold the suspect without bail he will be
arraigned later today Tony
all right Jonathan thank you very much